g1
e aí
é a primeira pergunta é o que que eu tô
fazendo aqui meu deus do céu não dá
tempo de ir embora porque tá todo mundo
assistindo eu não sei o que eu tô
fazendo aqui porque eu não sou formado
em raiva eu não sou formada nem na usp
gente tá não tenho nem doutorado não
inventei nada para ciência de útil
também não tem uma empresa unicórnio que
faturou milhões no meu deus do céu não
tem nenhuma história posso falar eu sou
uma impostora a fabris você é uma
impostora que que eu tô fazendo aqui
e aí
e essa pergunta e essa frase vídeo
perfeita né para quem vai fazer um deck
são paulo é perfeito para quem vai fazer
essa da escola e vou dizer para vocês
ela me acompanha há muito tempo não é de
hoje que ela me acompanha parece que a
qualquer momento alguém vai chegar onde
eu tô e perceber que eu sou uma farsa e
que eu não sou boa o suficiente para
fazer aquilo que eu fui chamado para
fazer isso me dá nervosismo estudando
ansiedade e fazer sua na mão e eu vou
contar uma história para vocês em 2008
eu entrei para um é o concurso né como é
que diz uma concorrência provas para ser
trainee de uma multinacional tá era mais
concorrida na época porque não é que era
mais legal trabalhar não era que mais
pagava para prevenir né tem ele tá
querendo dinheiro então todo mundo de
todas as faculdades eram milhares de
jovens com correndo para essa vaga de
trainee então como é que você faz nesse
aí manda o seu currículo
e aí tem a primeira fase prova de
português prova de matemática
conhecimento geral geopolítica redação
espanhol em inglês passou beleza vai
fazer outra fase terceira fase dinâmica
de grupo dinâmica de grupo como resolver
problemas todo mundo meio que com
correndo né por essa vaga passou vai
para entrevista entrevista em português
lá fui ela foi passando né foi para uma
entrevista em português aí chegava
e-mail você passou para próxima fase
falava meu deus do céu como que eles vão
descobrir que eu não sei que eu tô
fazendo aí de novo passou para mais uma
fase uma entrevista em inglês fala
direita com o sion da américa latina eu
falei jesus ele vai descobrir que que eu
tô fazendo aqui falando com esse se ou
que vai descobrir que eu não entendo
nada de ontem nacional de petróleo do
dólar ok mas lá fui eu fiz uma
entrevista com o dias depois recebi um
e-mail dizendo você passou um acerto
para que vaga
um crime desse ou eu falei como assim
podia ser de t.i. podia ser de
contabilidade de marketing e você tem
ido se ou seja é como se eu tivesse
passado em primeiro lugar para essa vaga
é aí eu meu deus que máximo camaieu tem
que eu tô fazendo aqui eu vão descobrir
a qualquer momento que eu não sei que eu
tô fazendo eu não posso não posso ter
treino desse ou não também calma aí tive
uma ideia né gente que a gente vai fazer
pedir conselho fui falar com um amigo
tão querido tão fofo se amigo eu falei
né você não vai acreditar eu passei para
ser trainee do senhor que que ele
responde fala sério se eu fosse ou eu
também ia querer uma mulher mulher
bonita aquela que você vai ter que
viajar com ele ele pode ser lá com você
desse lado com você no aeroporto nela te
apresentar para outros executivos
hoje eu olhei assim sabe que que eu fiz
tirei na carteirinha de feminista falei
que isso era machismo sexismo nem uma
aula para ele mentira a gente a sara foi
expectativa mas na realidade eu
concordei eu concordei com ele e sumir
eu desisti o pessoal do rh me mandar uma
mensagem onde você tá menina você sumiu
e eu inventei que ia morar fora falei
não disse que quer que eu vou lá fora
tem morar no estados unidos foi mal aí
desistir da vaga dos meus sonhos
gostaria de ter outro final para você
pode mas não eu desisti
o tempo passou eu trabalhei com várias
outras coisas né com publicidade com
venda trabalhando na televisão e fui
conhecendo várias outras mulheres então
mulheres poderosas bonitas mulheres de
sucesso inteligentes e comecei a
perceber que a gente tinha uma coisa em
comum nenhuma delas se sentia do
suficiente ou seja não era um lugar
externo que elas alcançavam que perdi
essa sensação de impostora não era um
lugar interno fui fuçar na internet
achei lá michelle obama falando eu achei
que eu nunca ia me encontrar na vida
pois nunca me achava bolsa e sente funk
michelle obama aí foi lá michelle
phipher falando parecia que cada dia que
eu chegava no set de filmagem eu
descobri que eu não sei atuar que eu era
uma farsa foi meu deus mais o michele e
falar com a michelle estagiária também
achava que ia ser mandado embora a
qualquer momento que não sabia mexer no
excel princess só eu e michelis não sou
eu e milhões de mulher
e pelo mundo que nunca se sentem boa
suficiente ou seja a gente tem uma
sociedade secreta de impostoras por aí
muitas e muitas mulheres sofrem disso e
poucas delas falam sobre isso então
decidi que não só eu ia combater nesse
número pastora como eu ia falar e ajudar
outras mulheres foi estudar né descobri
que esse termo foi usado pela primeira
vez nos anos 70 pela paulinho e klein
ela não tinha colocando um conjunto de
sentimentos que mistura insegurança medo
ansiedade quando você está próxima do
sucesso aí não perguntei metade dos
homens tem isso também os homens têm mas
há uma diferença que eu percebi gente a
seguinte você fala para um homem a frase
dele é sabe qual o problema é que
ninguém descobriu ainda a hora que verem
meu trabalho bom ver o meu valor hora
que bem valor do meu trabalho eu vou ter
sucesso e as mulheres ao contrário elas
pensam
é a hora que vem o meu trabalho vão
descobrir que não que eu não sei o que
eu tô fazendo aqui o que que eu estou
fazendo aqui tá certo então eu decidi
mapear que momentos são esses que a
gente pode é combater os gatinhos que
levam nós mulheres para esse lugar para
síndrome de postura e aí veio a seguinte
palavra que é perfeita né que chama em
tá cara que é isso que acontece a gente
impacta a gente está bota a gente boi
cota então cada vez aqui é o significado
é ímpar cada letra e evidência colocou a
gente não fala com a gente no ted para
gente ir no centro bolo forte na reunião
não passou senão da pastora que eu tô
fazendo aqui machismo não contribuiu
muito para isso gente sabe que a gente
chegar numa sala de reunião cheia de
ideias e quando você abre a porta o
pessoal da mesa fala olha que ele chegou
para enfeitar a nossa reunião você pensa
contou eu e o vaso de
tô tentando não vou falar nada sendo
vendo pastora p poder se referência que
a gente tem de mulheres no poder é muito
pouco muito pouco a gente vive de
referência para copiar a gente não
encontra isso gatilho para sempre
impostora avaliação eu acho que eu nunca
fiz uma prova na minha vida que eu achei
que tinha ainda que eu tinha ido bem e
vou dizer para vocês eu não achei fui
bem acho que eu nunca tirei uma nota
mais de 9 nunca achei que ia passar no
vestibular passei nos primeiros lugares
a gente nunca acha que vai passar e tem
que fazer mais e tem que fazer mais
confronto
e ninguém aqui foi ensinada confrontar
sabe porque quando a gente chega numa
casa e até bom separar nisso tem lá um
casal né de filhos um menino e a menina
a menina a gente falar que for falar tá
desenhando será que ela é comportado
assim aí que ótimo o juninho tá em cima
da árvore o juninho ele apronta demais
ser humano que é amor então a gente
repete tudo aquilo que a gente elogiada
e a gente foi elogiada para ficar quieta
para não confrontar para não dar
trabalho então quando a gente é colocada
nessa situação impostora e ascensão
ascensão beleza você fala bom quanto
melhor vamos sair no meu trabalho mas
segura eu vou ficar mas não é assim é
inversamente proporcional quanto mais
você sobe mais a pensa que não devia
estar lá não pertencimento o não
merecimento muitas vezes a gente acha
que é sorte e por final reconhecimento
trem aqui sabe falar obrigada depois de
um elogio porque geralmente a que quer
é bonita essa blusa emprestada eu
comprei num brechó não é velho imagina
pode barato e assim a gente não consegue
falar nem um obrigado então empacamos
lembro de todas essas situações para
saber que você tem que combater elas
porque elas são gatilhos da síndrome do
impostor mas tudo bem rafa vai ficar
aqui só falando problema né então vamos
falar né de tem que eu acho que são
alguns pensamentos para gente combater
essa síndrome porque infelizmente a
gente depois de tudo que eu estudei um
livro que eu tô escrevendo eu não me
sinto curada eu entro aqui no deck que
eu não falar agora sou eu eu passo pelo
mesmo processo mas quando a gente tem
consciência e tem algumas armas para
combater isso tudo fica mais fácil então
eu separei hoje aqui para falar para
vocês três né esses caminhos que a gente
precisa trazer a consciência então vamos
lá
a exterminadora do presente é isso que
as impostoras são sabe por quê porque
hoje a gente vive no passado e o passado
traz o que culpa eu tinha que ter
soldado mais eu tinha que ter trabalhado
mais eu tinha que ter um currículo mas
melhor a gente não manda me chamando
elas currículo que a gente nunca fica
bom porque a gente pensa deveria ter
feito aquilo no passado o passado
relacionado a culpa hoje eu tive no
futuro meu deus que tem um achado a
minha franja olho e ser um achado a
minha apresentação e o futuro traz
ansiedade então somos exterminadores do
presente enquanto a gente não viver no
presente que a gente vai ficar se
culpando pelo passado ou tendo ansiedade
pelo futuro foque no seu presente se
aproprie da sua história tudo que você
tem hoje segundo caminho muito
importante se coloca na terceira pessoa
porque você já perceberam que a gente
cresce aprendendo a se comunicar com os
outros então obrigada por favor a gente
elogia não bebezinho a gente até
eu te amo a gente quer certo que a gente
quer mas ninguém nunca nos ensina a
falar com nós mesmas como é que fala que
você mesmo então a gente acha que
assistam pensamento mais não é alguém
falando o dia inteiro para você tá você
não tá bonita você tá gorda que não é
bolso sempre você não vai conseguir se
coloca na terceira pessoa e pensa se
você falasse isso para alguém como essa
pessoa reagiria ninguém aguentaria ser
esse saco de pancada que a gente faz com
a gente mesmo então faz esse exercício
se você fala aí o que você fala para
você internamente essa bosta e fica 24
horas se você falasse isso para alguém
como que isso seria tóxico na vida da
pessoa e por fim é a frase que salvou
minha vida que realmente há uma frase
que me acompanhou repito ela todos os
dias de que todo julgamento é uma
confissão
e todo julgamento é uma confissão eu
entendi isso quando eu comecei a
perceber como que eu julgava as pessoas
o julgamento não é algum parcial ele
passa pela nossa história e passa pelos
nossos valores ele passa pela nossa
cognição são então um seu julga as
pessoas passando por todo esse processo
eo julgamento dos mais sobre mim o que
sobre elas e aí você começa a pensar que
isso de fora funciona da mesma maneira
se você tem medo do julgamento está
nervosa com julgamento não tenho que
você faça o melhor que você se saia
porque porque o julgamento que vai
passar por toda a história da outra
pessoa e isso realmente eu repito todos
os dias da minha vida para entender que
não adianta eu fazer esperando as
expectativas das outras pessoas que sim
eu sou boa o suficiente para fazer tudo
aquilo que eu determino a ser boa o
suficiente e é algo essa conquista ela
vem de dentro ela é interna não tenho
nada fora que vá
como perder a senhora da mistura então
eu faço a pergunta para vocês o que que
eu estou fazendo aqui na minha resposta
é eu sou a rafa brites e vim hoje falar
no ter dez são paulo e tô mexendo motivo
por isso obrigada beijo pra todo mundo
tá bom preferida e i